interview le besoin de rire de
l'actualité et des individus qui la
composent est incontournable mais
derrière le vernis de l'humour se trouve
un univers très riche entre les
réflexions que ça suscite et les dérives
toujours possible c'est ça qu'il faut
contre alors bougera au départ faut bien
préciser une chose ceci n'est pas de la
satire il faut dans un premier temps
définir le terme le concept de la satire
pour mieux comprendre un peu de
compagnie c'est quoi la satire la satire
c'est un genre littéraire qui allie
humour et critique sociale
donc on va inventer des histoires mais
pas dans le but de désinformer mais
plutôt dans le but de faire ressortir
des côtes et un peu absurde dans notre
société de grossir la réalité pour la
critiquer et là ça tire ça se distingue
de la caricature ou de la parodie où
l'on va vraiment exagéré des prêts de
quelqu'un ou quelque chose pour s'en
moquer parfois il peut avoir un mélange
des genres parce que la satire c'est un
peu plus sérieux que la parodie mais si
on prend par exemple le revoir qui est
un média satirique québécois donc dans
son titre le revoir c'est une parodie du
devoir mais dans les contenus
c'est vraiment de la satire déjà dans
l'antiquité avait de la satire et des
grands auteurs qui utilisaient la satire
dans leurs romans pour critiquer leur
époque par exemple mark twain
il ya eu charlie hebdo qu'on connaît en
france qui est un journal satirique
[Musique]
ici au québec on a eu la fin de vendetta
7h et foreman qui est aussi une émission
satirique
les bleu poudre aussi qui ont fait de la
satire à leur époque sur internet en ce
moment donc j'ai parlé du revoir il ya
aussi le graphe i7 satirique français
eddy onion qui américain et qui est très
très connu de mentionner bleu poudre on
parle là pierre brassard dans quelques
instants mais avant je qu'on fasse la
différence mais était clair entre
fausses nouvelles et s'attire y en a une
oui et puis beaucoup de sites de fausses
nouvelles utilise l'étiquette satire
pour se permettre de dire n'importe quoi
donc la satire on veut que les lecteurs
comprennent que ces faux ont vu que ce
soit dans le coup tandis que dans les
fausses nouvelles
l'intention est plutôt que les gens
prennent la nouvelle au sérieux on veut
souvent inventer des histoires très
exagérées très insolite
juste pour que les gens cliquent ou
encore ça va être pour désinformer les
gens donc on a vu par exemple durant la
dernière campagne présidentielle
américaine décide de fausses nouvelles
bases et en macédoine qui inventait des
histoires et qui voulait que les gens
croient à ces histoires là pour les
induire en erreur
là tout ce qu'on décrit il s'ajoute un
espèce de climat de confusion qui règne
sur internet et on sent que les gens
tombent dans le piège parfois ça arrive
des fois que les gens prennent de la
satire au sérieux on a eu un coup ici
très connu le journal de montréal
des gens ont pris leurs informations au
sérieux il ya une étude qui a été fait
d'ailleurs sur des sites satirique très
connu et les chercheurs voyait que
jusqu'à 15 % des gens croyaient que les
nouvelles satirique n'était vrai mais
donc dit onion qui est un site satirique
très célèbre son éditrice a déjà dit si
les gens nous prennent au sérieux c'est
qu'on a échoué à notre mission et dans
tout ça je me dis qu'il ya des choses
qu'on doit avoir l esprit pour ne pas
tomber dans les pièges
oui donc la meilleure solution c'est
d'identifier clairement la satire comme
tel alors google le fait dans ses
résultats de recherche facebook le fait
aussi dans son programme de vérification
des faits parce que de la vraie satire
même quand on dit que c'est de la satire
c'est quand même sens y rester drôle
tandis que dans les fausses nouvelles on
veut se moquer des gens qui tombent dans
le panneau et il ya une autre avenue qui
tenteraient de
le pc d'entraîner de l'intelligence
artificielle à reconnaître la différence
entre la satire et les fausses nouvelles
mais c'est pas encore au point d'autres
l'instant il faudra se fier sur sa
propre intelligence
on y va le fait de faire de l'humour un
peu que les politiciens et tout ça c'est
important dans une société assez basique
ça va empêcher les jeunes s'adonnent des
réactions des discussions surtout dans
le temps des fêtes
notre actif des fois un peu alléger un
peu la situation sinon politiciens
acceptent est là c'est bien c'est pas
trop qu'est ce qu'une femme politique à
l'humour c'est toujours une bonne chose
souvenez-vous de raymond beaudoin
ça nous manque ce genre de personnage
pas partie de québec revient au québec
plusieurs personnalités ont fait vivre
la satire au petit écran
parmi eux pierre brassard au début des
années 90 avec son personnage de raymond
beaudoin sa marque de commerce
ce point tessin crier gare devant les
personnalités publiques qui armé de son
micro de son appareil photo polaroïd et
de ces questions qui parfois dérange
bien brassard a longtemps incarné la
satire dans l'univers télévisuel au
québec une époque où on faisait les
choses autrement par un peu de cette
époque
la première fois j'avais l'air d'un
clown parce que raymond beaudoin avec
son veston bleu pozza vedène sa cravate
fausse barbichette et mon boulot il
prenait beaucoup de place il criait il y
avait un cri ils pompaient bon je n'ai
plus à me traiter avant chacun donc ça
détourne l airgas a attiré l'attention
pour la plupart des artistes
on était bien accueillie parce que les
gens comprennent elles la nécessité de
la satire
moi je pense qu'on en a besoin de la
satire parce que les gens se tiennent
informés avec tous les médias sociaux
les nouvelles sont sont partagés
les milliers de fois et candia rives de
quelque chose d'un peu créatif donc une
satire par rapport à un évènement on la
pologne
on aime soit on la partage donc à mon
avis ça permet d'avaler d'appel insisté
de nouvelles qui est très tragique ou un
peu plate
ça permet aussi de rire des politiciens
de rire des gens qui sont capables de se
défendre des figures publiés puis ça
fait ça fait du bien c'est pour digérer
apportait tout gérer mais je passais
d'accord avec moi ça peut être réfléchir
aussi sur ce qui se passe sur l'activité
en général un regard qui nous permet
d'aller un peu plus loin et même dans
notre réflexion
oui puis on peut voir oui c'est ça
souvent on un résumé sérieux à travers
la blague de l'événement le rire le
soulagement qu'on a entendu la blague
sur telles vedettes telles politiques
surtout les politiciens c'est celle a
répondu c'est la revanche du public
aussi indirectement combustible et moi
comme il y en eut pas ce que leur est le
personnage présent là ils n'oseraient
pas que je faisais vraiment beaudoin
c'est un gosse un journaliste raymond
beaudoin mais j'avais toujours
l'impression que j'avais le public
derrière moi parce qu'on allait voir des
acteurs qui dérangeait dans l'actualité
aussi on s'attaque à pas à des gens sans
défense et rideaux les exemples les plus
notoires abord raymond beaudoin c'est
l'ancien bruit ce biais de trudeau que
je suis allé voir à plusieurs reprises
dans mon parcours et la dernière fois il
me fut la bonne parce que l'aïe était un
peu exaspéré qu'est ce que ça a révélé
je pense qu'à l'époque il faut pas
oublier que j'ai reçus puis dans les
parties claque au visage chez ma belle
soirée
quand il m'a en guise mais un peu
agressé personnellement je n'ai pas été
surpris que je l'avais vu retourner des
journalistes pas nécessairement
physiquement mais c'était un acte
particulier alors ça ça révèle le
personnage basse et saint raymond et la
satire touche à ces bouts droits bien la
sélection il faut faire ça par exemple
il ya eu longtemps michel richard à
l'époque s'étaient mariés
l'individu elle se permet d'aller dans
tout l'état de choses avant d'avoir tous
les magazines à ses pieds et je me dis
c'est quoi
qu'est ce qui nous empêcherait de new
delhi c'est trop un cirque un spectacle
pour qu'on soit pas là je me souviens
qu'à la fin du topo il ya une dame qui
m'a engueulé on tournait la caméra
tournait je l'écoutais du côté du coup
thérapie juste après il ya un petit gars
qui est sorti le 10 et baumann ya quand
même des endroits il est chose qu'on
pourrait peut-être moins faire
aujourd'hui que raymond beaudoin faisait
à l'époque non c'est sûr que je serais
peut-être jamais parce que raymond
bonnot n'est jamais très loin
c'est à dire chez moi j'ai encore le
costume on me dit en fin de journée on
dit on ne dit pas d'aller voir justin
trudeau oui le monde a changé
je regardais la dernière campagne
électorale justin trudeau qui porte un
gilet pare-balles aux rassemblements
pierre en plus les gens que j'aimerais
aller voir ce sont des gens qui se fait
très très entre guillemets en vue à
l'époque ces gens là pour moi il me
paraissait je débutais presse c'était
inatteignable j'étais un peu j'ai encore
ce côté le groupe y aller à la chasse
ramener le trophée jusqu'au tu es là
mais vous savez c'est comme batman une
bataille encore qui je le dis
honnêtement est pas réglé puis les gens
m'écrivent souvent on veut qu'ils
ressortent mais je voudrais pas les
décevoir devrait pas que ce soit en
dessous de ce qu'on a vécu d'une utilité
dans la parodie imiter son beau frère
c'est déjà en faire une satire c'est lui
dire c'est un peu d'affection ça dépend
comment on le fait puis ça fait partie
de je pense depuis des années de nous ça
doit continuer yves